okay in our first story the fraud parade
continues man whenever a market gets hot
like we see in crypto and in startups
and the public markets when things get
overheated and the government's giving
away a bunch of free money then you
start to see a lot of corruption and you
see a lot of fraud uh today's fraud is
uh the sec has charged mobile data
seller app annie and their former ceo
with securities fraud and the company
will pay a 10 million dollar settlement
okay so here from the press release on
tuesday the sec announced they were
charging app annie and former ceo
co-founder bertrand schmidt with
securities fraud and they would be
forced to pay 10 million in a settlement
if you don't know about app annie they
help companies basically optimize their
mobile app performance so you can do
things like increase your downloads or
maybe move up in the app store rankings
you give them data they give you back
analytics about your product and then
the concept is they were supposed to be
taking all of that data from all of the
eight million apps they claim use the
service uh like downloads and usage
statistics how many people open it all
that stuff uh revenue estimates and then
they would sell that data in an
anonymized fashion uh to traders looking
to place bets on this data so people who
do you know major major trades
of course buy data from many different
sources you may have heard of this
before where satellite companies
were taking pictures of parking lots and
giving the parking lot data or maybe
port data how many ships were coming
into a port
as a proxy for economic activity whether
it's at a target or a city or a country
and so then you can place a bet on that
which means you know any information you
can publicly get that's not insider
trading right not exactly it's just you
getting an edge through information
there's a fine line between what's
insider and what's just really clever
data to get you could sit outside of a
tesla dealership count the number of
people going in and out and do that
every day or if you happen to be across
the street from a tesla dealership or a
starbucks what if you put a camera there
and you literally counted the number of
people coming in now to build software
to do that and then make trades based on
it seems like a logical thing to do if
you see the number of people coming to a
starbucks every day increase
you know you might want to increase your
bet just like counting cards isn't
technically illegal in blackjack if you
know there are more face cards in the
deck you can make a strategy on that but
of course the casino can kick you out in
this case the casino is the sec and
they'll look at the rules
so app annie uh not sure exactly what
the company's valued at right now but we
found a about a last investment of 63
million at a 500 or so million dollar
valuation their series e
but here's went wrong according to the
sec press release app annie and schmidt
understood that companies would only
share their confidential app performance
data with app annie if it promised not
to disclose their data to third parties
okay
so if you were running your app and you
were uber or twitter or some nascent
company you were com or headspace
whatever happens to be you were using
app annie to optimize yours you would
not want third parties to have your data
as a result app annie promised their
customers that the confidential data
would be anonymized and aggregated
before being sold to trading firms
according to the sec release what does
that mean okay we took all the games and
we said these are the number of hours
being played on games on iphones versus
android phones here's the number of
on-demand companies or ride sharing
companies
but they thought they were all being
anonymized obviously they weren't so
contrary to these representations
the order finds that from late 2014
through mid 2018 app annie used
non-aggregated and non-anonymized data
to alter its model generated estimates
to make them more valuable to trading
firms
according to the release app annie knew
that their customers were making
investment decisions based on their
estimates and they even shared
strategies on how the firms could use
the estimates to trade ahead of
quarterly earnings according to the sec
release so um here's a quote from the
director of sec's enforcement division
here app annie and schmidt lied to
companies about how their confidential
data was being used and then not only
sold the manipulated estimates to the
trading firm customers but also
encourage them to trade on those
estimates often touting how closely they
correlated with the company's true
performance and stock price in other
words schmidt was out there telling
people use my data buy my data you're
going to make more money trading stocks
is that insider trading no it's not
information from the company um
but in a way it's sort of like a
secondary
level of insider trading it's kind of
hard to describe right
because people gave that data but they
gave it under the
auspices of it being anonymized so you
know do you do insiders have an
advantage of course they do of course
they do anytime you have a lot of money
at stake and in some kind of gambling or
trading environment people will try to
get an edge and some people
actually take pride in getting an edge
that is illegal or not available you
know depending on if you want to be
charitable or if you want to be super
cynical about it in terms of fraud you
know this is serious fraud is it fraud
on the level of theranos where
the service doesn't work uh and you're
basically putting people's lives at risk
no
um you know 10 is bernie madoff in
theranos in my mind like premeditated
fraud
i put this you know in the 678 range
it's just somebody doing something super
unethical and they got busted and
there's no indication here if that
person has been banned
uh but usually there's a ban with these
things like they would be oh no actually
there is a ban app annie and schmidt did
not admit or deny the findings but app
ending will pay 10 million schmidt will
pay 300k and schmidt
will be prohibited from serving as a
director officer of a public company for
three years so i would say that's a
speeding ticket more than
a a real
uh serious
action it's a speeding ticket uh you
know i don't know if it's a slap on the
wrist the slap on the wrist would be
don't do it again i would categorize
this as you know a speeding ticket which
if you own a ferrari and you get like a
serious speeding ticket and you get your
license suspended for three years that's
kind of painful right if you if they
impound the car
this is kind of like you're a ferrari
you're doing 150 on the streets they
impound the car you lose your license
for three years so it's a serious
speeding ticket serious action and as i
said uh on cnbc the other day and i
think i said it on this week in startups
there's 800 unicorns now in my estimate
one out of 100 companies i invest in
or you know i meet with
sometimes you know well i'd say out of
the companies i've invested in 300 i've
seen in one percent of the cases things
that would be very concerning to me
maybe not made off there are no level
frauds but people doing things that i've
had to tell them like uh that's not a
good idea
if you are telling people these are our
customers on a slide let's say and half
of them are your customers and half of
them are in your pipeline
you may be exaggerating but exaggerating
when you're selling securities
securities fraud
um you know giving people data to trade
on now you're getting into securities
fraud so you have to just have a very
high
moral and ethical uh compass
when you are running a company i've seen
people do things they think are no big
deal like i'm not going to take a salary
but i'm going to have the company pay
for my apartment and i'm going to have a
corporate car that i put all my living
expenses on like then you're doing tax
evasion why is it tax evasion because if
you were supposed to get a salary you're
supposed to pay income tax and if you're
living and sleeping in your apartment
and you use one-third of it as an office
and two-thirds for a living
well then you should really be doing
one-third
uh as an expense against your personal
taxes or maybe the company pays for it
and you just have to talk to a tax
accountant and make sure you do these
things right
when you're trying to keep the momentum
going on an important project you may
need some extra help well fiverr
business puts a world of expert
freelancers at your fingertips so you
can get that project across the finish
line and be proud of the work plus
you'll get everything you need to
seamlessly integrate your new team
members into your workflow we love
fiverr here at launch and we've hired a
bunch of researchers and markers over
the years to help us finish some
important projects one of them we did we
needed to let everybody know in
australia that we're coming with launch
festival boom i hit the ground running
now they have fiverr for business they
created fiverr for business for folks
like us running companies who need to
have a vip concierge level of service
and their team of dedicated business
success managers bsms are going to help
you find the great talent to join your
team there are no more endless guessing
and interviews plus save and share your
favorite freelancers for future projects
find the freelancers you need to give
your next project just the boost it
needs to finish strong right now you can
sign up for fiverr for business
absolutely free for the first year one
year free and save ten percent on your
purchase on fiverr business with the
promo code jason just go to fiverr.com
business and don't forget that promo
code jason fiverr is spelled
f-i-v-e-r-r dot com okay fiverr.com
business promo code jason let's get back
to this epic episode